hi i'm ryan wright
and i'm michelle q welcome to reasons to
see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see
the conjuring
so let's [ __ ] our pants
reason to see number one the creepy
scares
this film has a you know it's got a
typical plot uh
family moves into a home and then it's
haunted because uh the family just has
really bad luck they've done nothing to
deserve this and something
happens where suddenly demonologists are
called in
to help save the day see what they can
do to exercise the demons
and this is based on a true story true
story which is roughly based
amplifies the fear a little bit makes it
even like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is real yeah the [ __ ] get
happy [ __ ]
so that makes it scarier and this film
is it's scary for the most part you know
it's
it's fun scares also too it's not like a
really fast-paced movie it's actually
like
slow building kind of tension but not
slow moving a lot at all
no no no no no it's paced very well what
i love about it is it's not full of gore
and blood
like i was watching it going why is this
rated r it could totally be pg-13
the lone ranger has more violence than
this movie the lone ranger
my name is tonto don't ever do that
again
i'm gonna speak over you every time we
talk you know what i liked about this
movie is that
they weren't just let me throw scary
[ __ ] at you oh yeah it's
smart scares it's very it's suspense
building
when [ __ ] happens like you're you're
freaked out you're like go [ __ ]
like damn like it's what i will say
the trailer kind of gives away a little
too much
especially in the first hour but you
know even in the first hour there's some
really good scary stuff that goes on
there's a moment so it's terrifying but
here's what i'll say for the most part
it's thrilling
it's suspenseful throughout there's a
resonating fear going on
it's not like you're going to [ __ ] your
pants like how everyone else is making
it out to be
still it's worth your time reasonably
number two
the directing and cinematography i love
the direction of this movie james wan
the as you can see by the poster uh the
director of saw
and insidious uh this guy very very good
director
most of the time this dude has pulled
off what i think is one of his better
movies he's ever done it's a smart
film and you know i got to give the
writing credit too throughout all these
categories that's a lot of throwback
vibe you can tell this guy's paying a
lot of homage
to uh you know those 70s types of
thrills you know there's a lot of the
zooming in kind of stuff and uh it's
beautiful
beautiful cinematography absolutely
wonderful it amplifies the experience
it reminded me um of the shining
yeah not in necessarily the story but
just the way that's spilling the weights
the tone and stuff
even like the way things are revealed is
it's like the shining
it does have that old-school type of
scary feel to it
the direction of it he really knows how
to work with his actors he
he cares enough to tell a movie based on
the characters itself because
the film is mainly a drama with horror
in it
it's not exactly the other way around
and
he knows the foundation of this is good
characterization and he totally brings
that to the table here reason to see
number three
the warrens so i don't really
like watching scary movies and um i
actually
wanted to see this one because of the
warrens they are
a real life or they were a real life
team of paranormal investigators
lorraine warren is actually still alive
today and
they documented like 10 000 paranormal
cases or something
throughout their career so it was
definitely interesting to see
this story kind of told from the
perception of the warrens
yeah yeah it's not a biopic but it it
makes you
you could somewhat see them doing a
sequel not based off the same family but
based off the warrens
right you know and it they're they're
great characters you know
one thing they achieve is they're
definitely not con artists they're
they're so sincere in their portrayals
patrick wilson
uh who who surprisingly does not take
off his shirt in this movie you know
i was wondering when that was gonna
happen and he doesn't take off his shirt
and insidious but he
is in his underwear at one point with a
shirt on so that compensated for it
this movie he uh he's fully clothed the
whole time
the whole time what the [ __ ] pw and vera
for mega
migma from vagina or something i told
her
italian last name yeah and uh she's
beautiful to look at she's i think she's
in her 40s if she is a mom
milf m-i-l-f milf they're trying to
debunk anything prior to to
see if it's not in paranormal they're
not just like oh let's go find the
ghosts you know they're
trying to use scientific methods in a
way find out what's going on
like the first step they take is is this
paranormal or not
is this something that's like is it the
pipes going on in the house that are
freaking you out like
what is it you trust them as characters
and the way they talk they're not
playing up the roles
yeah they just seem like regular human
beings and this is just
part of their conversation the
performances of them are very strong
and the chemistry between patrick wilson
v vera for me clear vf is really great
to watch and every time they're on
screen you are just
pulled into the movie and like all right
what's gonna happen like yeah they're
the best parts
they say every time they're on the
screen you're like all right on the
treat again here we go
you're just like waiting for them to
kind of they're like the rescuer isn't
a little bit like in this movie you know
they're the ones that you count on
you're like oh my god please help these
people
solve it it's cool to have characters
who feel a sense of that you feel safer
when you're around them yet
you can still inject fear when they you
know so yeah
it's great reason to see number four the
supporting cast
most of the supporting cast is the the
family that has
the worst luck in the world and the the
head of the family is a ron livingston
who you might know from office space
jackson city and uh i remember he was
amanda brothers
and he's only had one real hit hasn't he
the guy
he's back and he i really like the
portrayal of the father because the
father's not a [ __ ]
idiot like how most horror movie dads
are
you know he's very reasonable he's
understanding you get the sense that
he's open-minded and stuff he's not like
i'm the head of the house and you guys
are crazy
you know he gets on board pretty fast
you know and he does a great job or
another very sincere performance
and uh i think the other one that stands
out the the mother whose name i can't
remember but she's in the trailers
the one with the clapping hands yeah
yeah lily taylor
live tyler whatever yes but anyway um
love tyler she doesn't live tyler's in
this movie yeah
steven tyler's in this movie that's
right stephen tyler yeah as the mother
carolyn
parent yeah it was very distracting but
he does a great job but anyway
uh she does an excellent job i don't
want to give away some
i don't want to give away the movie a
lot of the great scary moments uh they
do revolve around her character when
she's terrified like you feel that tara
itch it's
it's like oh so eerie i really liked
the the little the girls in the movie
a lot of you know of course paranormal
[ __ ] happens to them and
they just that one girl who was in white
house down
i think her name was joey king or
something like that she had this one
scene and she just
she does a great job oh i know what
you're talking about and when you watch
it you know what we're going to talk
about
like there's this one scene that she
owns and because of it
you're so [ __ ] scared it's great
you all know what i'm talking about when
you see it and you're going to be like
they don't do much but
it's terrifying there's some other fun
characters too they got this asian guy
in there
he's asian and uh they don't you know
emphasize the fact that he's asian
but you're watching it going he's asian
hmm interesting
this is a 70s movie you weren't
distracted by the fact that he was asian
for a song
a little bit i thought they were gonna
point out like some asian thing you know
like hey
is i thought it would be something like
oh whatever man i'm chinese that's why i
do that yeah yeah
yeah i thought he was gonna say i
thought there was a specific reason he
was asian
reason to see number five the production
design
yeah this movie really brought the 70s
back to life i love like
the hair and makeup especially it looks
very authentic you know that
because of the cinematography the way
everything's captured it it looks
very real it looks like you're back in
the 70s in a lot of ways the wardrobes
and everything was great the
just every all of it just looked like
the 70s really good
job diane
no you don't have anything no you don't
get anything you said everything you
said everything yeah you don't want to
dive into the production design
you don't think our viewers want to hear
more about the production design i think
that's all
that needs to be said look here's what i
know
when fans turn into a movie review show
they want to hear about the technical
stuff
not the performances and the directing
and the writing yeah no one cares about
that no no no no who gives a [ __ ] about
it i don't want to know about how
accurate the costumes were yeah
it's like how detailed were they i know
how the average audience is and when
they watch a movie
the most common reaction they want to
receive is
wow look at those costumes they must
have spent
hours on that [ __ ] i wonder how much
research went into figuring out yeah
this kind of cost
they must have done a lot of googling
reason to see number six
the effects excellent the effects
in this film they are scary specifically
the makeup effects
they are so good when it comes to this
[ __ ]
from just appearance you are terrified
because it doesn't look like cgi
it looks like whoa that's a real [ __ ]
ghost and that's what they look like you
know
it's pretty terrifying stuff what i love
about this film
is they leave a lot of the fear up to
your own imagination like the actors are
so good that
they see something that's in the dark
corner and you know they're so
terrified and it's so believable their
terror that you start
couldn't you start conjuring up the
the worst thing possible that could
occur
and so you you that's what's cool is
when they actually show them
they are just as scary if not scarier
than what you imagined one of the things
that i actually liked is that it doesn't
look super cgi
like what was that movie that we saw
with the the last scary movie that we
saw
oh mama mom no
mama um to me the effects were a very
obvious cgi which was fine for that
movie but in this movie it doesn't look
cgi
it's like [ __ ] this looks like real [ __ ]
that could like happen
oh the whole cast and crew do a great
job on bringing a world together that
this feels believable which which is
weird because it makes it fun
and uh it makes you believe that this
stuff is possible which makes you go i
better start praying to god more
so i go to heaven instead of getting
possessed by a demon
i love you lord i just want to point
that out i'm sure you're watching this
god
thank you god is on youtube on youtube
right now going hey you're talking to me
yeah thanks bro he's probably waiting
for our only god for gives review
reason to see number seven the scooter
they have like eerie [ __ ] music that
just like stings your ears
and you're like [ __ ] i'm terrified it
like makes you screech
it definitely amplifies the fear and the
scariness of the movie but this movie
does not rely on the music to make it
scary yeah it's not bombarded with music
they don't like do a jump cut and then
it's like they blast the music to make
you jump yeah like they're they're
moments that make you jump just because
they're [ __ ]
there are times where i literally was
holding on to her
for like a five to ten second period
because like this person was just saying
something to someone i'm like oh
and that was when silence was going on
reasons not to see number one
not entirely original okay
um yes hate [ __ ] this
movie is not entirely original no but i
don't think that's actually a reason not
to see this movie
i think if you're someone who's very
close-minded you will instead go
this is not it's it's supposed to be
homage style
so this is more of a it's not a reason
not to see it but it's more of a reason
not
it's more of a not a reason to see this
movie if that makes any sense
don't go in there expecting like oh i've
never seen this before because it's
supposed to be
familiar but here's what i'll say it
still feels fresh
even though you're in familiar territory
a different take on an old tale
in a way and it's still freaking scary
and i think that's what matters when you
see a scary movie is it
is it entertaining and scary or are they
just throwing scares at you
and they're not just throwing scares at
you they don't think the audience is
stupid and just wants
cheap thrills you're definitely haunted
by this movie
ryan's consensus a creepy fun time
is the reason to see the conjuring a
creepy fun time is the reason to see the
conjuring
first there was a baby now i'm hearing
pipes from the neighbors
great great this is awesome this is
awesome
you know you ask people to keep it down
they don't know [ __ ] about what that
means i hope
demons attack my neighbors don't say
that no no that's what's supposed to
happen that's scary
no no i'm gonna put red blood on my
house
and on the door so the ghosts don't come
in didn't you read the old testament
yeah that's exactly why yeah moses said
if you want to keep demons out you're
supposed to
that's also for the jews the jews oh
only the jews can put
red blood on their doors it's cheap
split
a sheep's blood yeah oh i never said
human blood well i'm just saying
yeah michelle's consensus
a good freaky time with the movies
promising to bring you some scary dreams
afterwards
is the reason to see the conjuring good
freaky time the theaters
and scary dreams afterwards
is the reason to see the conjuring
apparently you're gonna get freaky when
you watch this movie
no i don't mean like that like it
definitely you'll be able to sleep
after seeing this movie but but you
might need some melatonin
to help you out expect to have some
scary dreams
and uh yeah
and if you're jewish paint your door
alright guys checking out our review for
the conjuring
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and
tell us what is your favorite horror
film from the 70s
and if you'd like to check out more
reasons to see episodes
click the link right here and if you
want to follow us on facebook click the
link right here
like us we'll talk back to you if you
comment to us
because we uh we don't have a big enough
base yet
to to not talk back to you we're not
snobby yet
we're not egotistical yet i hope you
guys don't get to that point
well i want to get to the bar i'll be
like oh fans
i'm just kidding never treat you guys
that way love you forever
and if you want to follow us on twitter
click right here
and last but not least if you'd like to
get updated every time a new
review is out make sure to subscribe
click that button click it right there
or else a haunting
area that's floating between us yeah
click it or hauntings will happen to you
bad things will happen that's scary no
i'm just saying if they subscribe
they're going to be fine it's like the
antidote
click it or else you will not be
possessed by a demon
simple as that do you want to get
positions click it or else
they're saying if they click it they
will get possessed no i'm saying they
will not be possessed
so make sure to make that clear okay
click it so you don't get possessed i
thought that's what i said what are you
doing
i'm trying to save their lives right now
you said click it otherwise or else you
will not get possessed
oh is that what i said yes
let's play it back okay apparently i did
say that
i'm sorry sorry it's okay bad grammar
it's okay just thought you'd want to get
the right point across
you